перш за все ми маємо говорити про
здатність наших компаній працювати
розвиватися відновлюватися в Україні
друге питання - це працевлаштування Я
сьогодні все більше чую про те що в нас
дуже низька зайнятість і багато людей
шукає роботу достойно роботу і третє
питання це наповнення бюджету
фінансування армії і це абсолютно
очевидно ми маємо зрозуміти що країна
має використовувати всі внутрішні
резерви для того щоб армія була
забезпечена Ми не можемо опиратися лише
на гроші які ми можемо позичити чи
надрукувати ми маємо розуміти що дуже
багато що залежить від нас і ми не все
зробили ми маємо переосмислити дуже
багато речей все в руках знаєте треба
підходити більш системно і відповідально
Якщо ми будемо зараз схилятись до
якихось там існуючих раніше правил або
до якихось норм які нам здається вони от
є стандартними маємо їх застосовувати ні
країна зараз в такому стані що або ми
виживемо або ні